so I saw someone shared on Facebook an
article I don't remember where it was
from
another article about millennial men and
it was talking about the ways that
millennial men have reinvented or
reshaped masculinity and one of those
ways is that we are apparently more
emotionally vulnerable and more open
about our feelings and you hear this a
lot nowadays this is a this is an
improvement an improvement on the on the
male
gender is that now as we are more
enlightened and more progressive younger
men tend to be more open eager to share
our feelings and to talk about our
feelings and I think that's generally
true that a lot of men these days do
seem very open about talking about their
feelings men and women but it's always
been the case for women women probably
even more so now we're all kind of
trending in this direction of sharing
and oversharing and constantly and we
love you know the thing we love to talk
about men and women is we love talking
about our stress how stressed we are our
anxiety oh my gosh I have so much
anxiety I'm so stressed so much anxiety
I'm stressed I'm busy look at listen to
me but I'm so busy everyone you want to
hear about how busy I am
that's the thing I've noticed people
love talking about how busy they are how
little sleep they got the night before
how stressed they are and about their
anxiety that's just we love talking
about and I think it's kind of a status
symbol because if while I got you know I
don't get a lot of sleep and I'm busy
means I'm obviously an important person
so I get the admiration of being an
important person but I also get a little
bit of pity too so it's a nice little
it's admiration with this nice thick
coating this icing of pity on top of it
and it just makes for one sweet cupcake
I guess as far as as far as we're
concerned
I know I'm gonna differ a little bit
with with some people though because
although I recognize that men are more
emotional these days and more willing
and anxious and eager to talk about
their feelings I don't see it
necessarily as an improvement I think
we're losing something of what a man is
supposed to be especially in the home
and in the context of a marriage or you
know as both a husband and a father so
I've been thinking about as I've been
thinking about this my mind went back to
a story that I read in a book called The
Gulag Archipelago which is actually a
feat a three-volume work written by
Solzhenitsyn and it's a great classic
series of books not exactly pick-me-up
errs it's about it's a history of the
Soviet labor camp system so if I'm
looking for lessons about marriage
obviously the first place I look if I'm
looking for insights into marriage I'm
gonna look at a book about the Soviet
labor camp system that's because you
know that's where
I just I I think it wasn't the second
volume there's this quick anecdote that
Celgene Houston relays he he's talking
about it he gives a general history of
the labor can system he also talked
about his own experiences he spent
several years in the gulag himself and
he kind of intersperses his own
experiences within the larger tale of
the history of Soviet Russia which
not to spoil it for you but if I had to
summarize the two volumes that I've read
if I had to summarize two thousand pages
I would say it all boils down to this
Soviet Russia not a fun place it turns
out actually not not a great place if
you ever get in a time machine or trying
to decide where to go don't go to Soviet
Russia because you will end up at a
gulag and you're not going to enjoy it I
know it's kind of a shocker
so he
he recounts one scene in the book that I
thought was the most powerful
illustration of married love of of at
least the most powerful illustration of
a husband's love that I've read anywhere
outside of the Bible
and it stands in
contrast to this idea of the overly
emotional open constantly sharing and
oversharing man so this is the story
takes place at a prison camp sometime in
the 1920s I believe
a man named ass organ who's been
arrested on some trumped-up charge as
was common in Soviet Russia and he was
scheduled to be executed by firing squad
and on the day that he was scheduled to
be executed he was told he's gonna be
executed it just so happened that his
wife had already boarded a boat and was
on his on her way to come visit him of
course not knowing about any of this
he wanted to see his wife one more time
and he certainly didn't want her to come
all that way and then discover that he'd
just been killed
now I'm sure he was also worried that if
she showed up and he'd just been
executed what he was being executed that
they may arrest her for knowing about it
because that's the way things worked in
Soviet Russia
is that if your family member was
arrested whatever happened to them
whatever their fate was wherever they
ended up whether it was in a camp in
Siberia or six feet underground you
weren't allowed to know and so if she
did find out that may put her in
jeopardy so he pleaded with the with the
guards and asked them to allow him to
see his wife one last time when she
comes and just to spend some time with
her and he assured the guards that once
she leaves he will offer himself up to
be executed and the guards agreed but of
course the condition is you can't tell
your wife you can't even hint at it
not come to find out or suspect that
there's something bad about to be
happening about to happen to you so not
he couldn't even let a facial expression
cross his face that may tip her off we
spent two or three days with her they
were together the whole time and he
never hinted he never let on except for
one brief moment when they were taking a
walk by a lake and his wife looked over
and caught him for a moment clutching
clutching his head in torment and agony
thinking about what he was about to face
and she asked him what was wrong and he
quickly said nothing
and it finally when her visit was over
she got on the boat the boat was pulling
away and as the boat was pulling away he
was already undressing
and preparing to be shot
now I find this so powerful because it's
an example the most extreme example I've
encountered of a man shouldering a
burden carrying a cross for his family
being in emotional anguish and not
sharing it not talking about it keeping
it to himself carrying the load by
himself
and this is what men
um not quite to this extent but
hopefully most of us but this is
basically what we are meant to do for
our families we are meant to shoulder
burdens to carry across
we're told to love our wives like Christ
loved the church and we know that Christ
died for the church he suffered and
sacrificed
and he also didn't complain either he
did it with patience and grace and love
there was only there was just the one
the one moment the one very human moment
in the garden at Gethsemane where Jesus
wanted some of the apostles there in
this really vulnerable painful moment
for Christ but famously they fell asleep
on the job and so they couldn't even
give him that little bit of comfort but
one time that he asked for it so that's
what we're called to do
to strive to carry the largest portion
of the burden that we can and to do it
without complaining without holding it
against our wives or our children
without resentment without demanding
acknowledgement without martyring
ourselves without feeling the need to
constantly talk about it we're called in
other words to be stressed and to have
anxiety and not constantly say oh I'm so
stressed I'm so stressed out everyone
listen to me about my stress I have so
much anxiety listen
no we're called to sometimes just shut
up
and deal with it
and not force everyone around us
including our wives to accompany us in
our self-pity and misery all the time
I think as modern men we tend to make
one of two mistakes when it comes to
this or perhaps we make both mistakes we
could number one flat-out refuse to
carry the burden or to carry any burden
at all we may allow ourselves and some
husbands allow our happy to allow their
wives to just carry the entire burden by
themselves a lot of some husbands are
fine letting their wives do all the work
feel all the stress while they go out
and they go downstairs and play video
games or watch porn I think especially
of the families where you see them at
church and the mother is there with her
kids and she's trying to keep them all
in line in the pew the husband's nowhere
to be seen because he's at home and his
pajamas watching TV the spiritual
formation of a child is a very difficult
thing and keeping kids quiet in church
is just the this the easiest aspect of
it so very it could be a very painful
challenging thing to
shoulder that burden the burden of
spiritually of putting your children on
the right path spiritually and guarding
them against all the dangers the
spiritual dangers that are out there and
some men are perfectly fine allowing
their wives to take all of that on
completely alone and it is
to call it shameful is is a massive
understatement
the second mistake we may make is well
okay we may do our part to some extent
shoulder some of the burden at least but
we've listened to much to modern notions
of manhood
we have listened to much to modern ideas
about how the genders are supposed to
interact we've become too anxious to
take art the culture up on its
invitation for us to spill our guts
constantly and to complain about our
stress and to share every last anxiety
that we have with the world and with our
wives I think there are men who you know
they'll tell their wives everything
every word every fear
if they're in pain emotional physical
whatever they'll make sure they're why
even know it they'll make sure everyone
around them knows it
now here's the thing of course we should
share quite a bit with our wives and
there was a time when men were obviously
too closed up to silent they were just
to close the book like robots in the
home he had no emotion whatsoever and
that meant that they had really no bond
you know there's there's it's hard to
have the intimacy it's hard to have bond
with your wife when you're not letting
her in at all
but I think we've overcorrected now
we've overcompensated some of us
and if we had to choose between the two
extremes I think we're better off on the
silent you know the strong silent type
end of the spectrum then on this side of
the spectrum
we're we're so in touch with our
emotions that we're just constantly
eager to share them with everyone not
just our wives but the other day I saw
on my newsfeed and this is not an
uncommon sight you see this all the time
I saw a guy an adult male probably about
my age unleash a whole torrent of
personal complaints and anxieties right
there on the internet for everybody to
see for public consumption I don't know
if this guy is married but if he is I
can only imagine how often his wife must
be forced to listen to him complain and
moan about every will worry and
misfortune and heartache that he has
I think a balance is needed here
but the fact remains that sometimes I
believe a man has to carry a fear a
worry a concern a pain
keep it to himself carry it himself
I think a man has to sometimes be
willing to be stressed out and not show
it tired and not show it fed up and not
show it exhausted stressed out anxious
whatever and not show it
to carry it with dignity
you
um
not to feel the need to vent I guess
that's what we call it these days is
venting
and I don't want to get off on a tangent
here but venting is
generally an entirely selfish pursuit
it usually when we when we say we're
venting to somebody whether it's our you
know spouse or anybody what we say we're
venting what that means is we're just
piling toxic fumes and negativity upon
it right on top of some unsuspecting
innocent person because it makes us feel
better it's it's it's really it's like
rigueur it's just vomiting negativity
right on top of someone's a head and say
I just had to vent I hope you don't mind
and then the person they have now
they're covered in your negativity and
they're like okay what am I supposed to
do with this thank you for unleashing
all of that on me that's men and women I
think I think
all of us all men and women well we're
these days we're all a little bit too
eager to vent and to constantly complain
all the time but a man especially I
think has to be willing sometimes to
come home from work where he deals with
not only the stress of earning a living
but also the underlying stress a
constant stress of being a being
responsible for sustaining and feeding
his family and the worries that come
with that the what-ifs what bends all
the different things but he has to come
home and be immediately thrust back into
family life and the duties of family
life with all of those concerns and
stresses and responsibilities that come
with that and he has to make that
transition suddenly like flipping a
switch just like that and with without
always letting on how exhausted a burden
he feels
because not everything should be shared
sometimes a man should be willing to be
a man and carry it himself
that's not to say that he can never
speak with his wife about anything
hopefully his wife will understand what
her husband does for the family and what
he goes through and she'll try to give
him a break even if he doesn't ask for
one and hopefully he'll try to give her
breaks hopefully they have a marriage
like that but there should still be that
quiet dignity that quiet strength which
shoulders and carries and indoors and
does it in a way that isn't always
noticed
and isn't always begging for
appreciation and for acknowledgement
but he just fulfills his duty in love
and sacrifice
I think that's what's missing
not in every case but that's what's
missing generally from American manhood
is quiet
strength and dignity
that is that's that's part of a man's of
a man's role
I think
just a thought just a thought from a
Soviet labor camp thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening
you have a great day Godspeed